today we're talking about how the reveal
trailer for modern warfare 2 is getting
just a little bit closer and halo
infinite season 2 is having some
turbulence
according to a new report modern warfare
2's reveal trailer could air at an event
when e3 was supposed to be and will
focus on the campaign another leak
suggests that activision will release
the modern warfare 2 campaign trailer on
june 2nd but this is likely just the
beginning of activision's marketing and
promotion efforts for the game jeff
keeley's summer game fest event takes
place on june 9th and xbox's summer
showcase is slated for june 12th whether
or not modern warfare 2 shows up at
either of those however is unknown the
report also states that modern warfare
2's multiplayer will be revealed in
august whether or not there will be a
tie-in war zone event as a part of the
expected announcements is also unknown
if you didn't know modern warfare 2 will
be joined by a new warzone game this
year as well but it still remains to be
seen what this game will be and how the
cosmetics from the original war zone
might carry forward into the next game
both cold war and vanguard were released
in the month of november so we'll have
to see if modern warfare comes out in
the usual slot or sooner given vanguard
performed below expectations modern
warfare 2's multiplayer will also
reportedly include a mode called dmz
that is a spin on an extraction type
experience the campaign meanwhile is
expected to continue the story of task
force 141 and focus on colombian drug
cartels although a teaser in the logo
reveal likely points to singapore which
wouldn't be surprising given the series
usually hops around the world and in
other shooter news halo infinite
developer 343 industries has
acknowledged that the season 2 lone
wolves launch this week has been bumpy
with players reporting a number of
issues with the latest update on twitter
microsoft's joseph staton said quote we
are indeed taking your feedback to heart
especially regarding map jumps and speed
running we're reviewing options and
we'll have more news to come halo
infinite's new update also broke some
challenges related to the new last
spartan standing mode some related
challenges for the interference event
were not tracked properly but that
should be fixed now halo's john yuncevic
explained quote there may be a delay if
you leave early but all progress should
count towards the match once it finishes
in the background to help make up for
the issues 343 is giving everyone who
logs in during the interference event 5
xp boosts and 5 challenge swaps next
week 343 will reduce the difficulty of
some event challenges and further tweak
them so completing them earns two levels
of the event pass halo infinite players
have also reported issues with the new
battle rifle changes the br and other
weapons are now jamming but this is
related to a bug use of it confirmed
that a fix is coming
shout out to the halo community because
you're all practicing patience every
single day and i admire it but all right
let's end the week with a random story
about a rare wii that you can buy if
you've got deep pockets as the story
goes defunct publisher thq commissioned
a gold-plated nintendo wii to be
delivered to buckingham palace and
presented to the queen of england as a
part of a marketing stunt to promote big
family games unfortunately the queen was
unable to accept the gift as strict
security measures at the palace resulted
in the console being sent back to thq
and after the company went bankrupt the
queen's wii eventually found its way
into the hands of a collector
specializing in developer hardware the
console was then sold and has now wound
up on the auction block once again so
how much is this wii console and
controller plated in 24 karat gold well
the previous auction started the bidding
at 300 000
although this new auction's highest bid
at the time of recording this is
currently 2
dollars and this is perfect because if
you don't know what to get your mother
for mother's day yet you could always
bid on this when
give her a picture of it on sunday
because it won't be shipped to you in
time most likely and then when it comes
in and you'll be like look what i got
this is amazing wow
such the provenance i hope you all have
a great weekend shout out to all the
mothers out there celebrating mother's
day this sunday i'll see you on monday
[Music]